recommendations for when you're  sentenced to 38 years in federal prison  as you guys may know trial was today i  wore a tie i studied up i watched  legally blonde joshua won i got to give  the guy props i defended myself and i  thought i did a pretty good job but that  lawyer that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]  let's go to the bedroom  [Music]  if you guys don't hear from me for a  while and oh oop  [Music]  let me turn off the lights hold on you  know after the trial just kind of ran up  very fast hello  okay we're good all right  okay okay i feel like if you try to kill  somebody and it doesn't work that's your  punishment you failed at what you wanted  to do why should you be punished on top  of that it didn't work he's with debra i  would like to recommend  it is about a nice man who loves his mom  [Music]  you